[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers my friends
this is gunjan here
welcome to my 40th episode of chess trap
series
in this episode i am going to show you a
wonderful
high profile queen trap which in fact
none other than carpo himself fallen
into
and the good point is even though let's
say in few lines
white can save the queen black still get
an advantages position
okay opening start with queen's gambit
accepted
that is d4 d5 c4
and now black accept the pawn with d
capture c4
now in the recent time knight to f3 and
e3 doesn't give white any advantage
so the modern theory suggests that white
should continue with
e4 grabbing the space in the center
and trying to regain the bond back
okay now black plays some forcing moves
starting with knight to c6 attacking on
d4
and it is ill-advised for y to continue
with
d5 because after knight to e5
not only black will play knight to d3
and obtain the bishop pair
but this position always slightly favor
the black cap so nope that's not the
right idea
white has to keep his center and
accordingly
the most popular choice here is bishop
to e3
protecting the d4 pawn
okay we have another piece develop with
tempo
knight to f6 and the same story
if e5 the knight to d5 and that knight
is
well centralized so white has to defend
his center once again
with knight to c3
and now comes the final jab in the
center
with e5
well at first sight this looks very
strange because it allows white to gain
the space on the queen side
with d5 and black has to move away
the c6 knight and yes indeed
it looks so promising for the white camp
except
black has this very tricky reply
knight to a5 setting up a platform
for our cunning upcoming trap
here if you open and continue with queen
to a4 check
then that will transpose to the same
trap but
one of the worst version so accordingly
the correct response here is first
knight to f3
attacking on e5 and when black defend
with
bishop to d6 now white lash out
with queen to a4 jack
so as you can see now there is a double
attack
and the only way to save the knight is
to play c6
but nope we are not interested in
passive defensive positions
we are here for the fun and tricks and
traps
and that's why bishop to d7
a fitting reply saying white
okay go ahead take my piece
and after that trap has been set
right there with this very cunning
but very surprising move
asics
and suddenly you can see that queen is
literally running out of the square
black's next threat is very obvious he
wants to play
b6 and trap down this white sweetie
well here white has tried various
responses
and in fact as per the database
there are more than 40 games reached to
this position
where black winning ratio is tremendous
first let me show you what happens when
carpool reached to this position
by accident and he decided to get
out of this gel with bishop capture c4
and his big idea is after b6
white sacrifice the whole queen with
queen captures a6 rook captures a6
and now bishop captures a6 and if you
count the material here
white has rook knight and a pawn for
whole queen
which i don't think so enough as it has
been confirmed
by the chess engine well it was just
because of he was mighty carpo he
managed to draw the game
but i have my doubt any of your opponent
can get that result when they reach to
this position
well to understand how dangerous this
position
is for the wide i'd like to show you a
model game
where white who is in excess of 2600
rated player
continue with knight to e2
and his idea is very obvious queen can
now have access of
c3 and the d2 square however
just one move knight captures e4
and black says nope
i'm going to take the control of those
squares and again
my threat is very obvious b6
entrapping your queen
okay white thing this is not enough as
he continue with
castle on the queen side so that
his queen can now come to the even
square
but doing all these sort of moves what
white forget is
his king is now a big time target
and rightly so black continued with
c3 ripping apart the whole
coincide
well don't forget this queen excess has
been blocked up
so again white response is force
he has to take measure to save the queen
and in fact he did with the move b4
okay we have some forcing moves b6
attacking the queen queen to e3
and now no prize for guessing black's
next reply
yup you got it a5
trying to get a discover attack
so again white queen move out of the way
with queen to b3 but after a captures b4
it is confirmed that even though black
is a piece down
this is a dream position for any black
player
look how quickly game finish as
one inaccurate move played by wide that
is knight to g3
and black give white this root shock
boom
and believe it or not white can
resign the game well
in the game he continued with queen
captures a3 and
lost after few moves it's worth to note
it
why this move has been forced
let's check out what are the problems
white is facing in this position
number one if we continue with queen to
c3
then after the move b3
white position can hardly survive
so that is right out of the equation
well what about queen to b1
more or less same story as this time
around
our c pawn do the damage with
c2 attacking two pieces
white cannot play queen to c2 because of
rook to c3
and white queen is a goner
so another option is king captures c2
but this time around our knight will do
the wonderful job
yup knight to c3 and again
white position is completely crumbling
well last but not least what happens
if white continue with queen to c4
which looks obvious from this position
but i'm afraid it will not save the
disaster
as after following just two moves knight
captures g3
h captures g3 and queen to e8
white can literally pack his back and go
home
as black onslaught cannot be stopped
now before we leave i like to quickly
point out
two good moves by the white cam where
white can avoid the strap
but in the scenario it is black who get
the upper hand for example
knight to a4 is one of the main line
but after the following forcing
continuation
queen to e7 threatening bishop to b4
so a3 stopping it
and now comes knight captures e4
once again the same old nuisance b6
the best what can do over here is bishop
capture c4
and after both the side castle
[Music]
the star move b5 definitely gives black
a upper hand after bishop to d3
knight to f6 as you can see black has a
double threat
first capturing the knight and then
second e4
and unfortunately for white he cannot
defend
both of them after knight to c3
e4 knight captures e4 and knight
captures e4
yes indeed white has awarded the trap
but engine suggests that this position
favors the black because of the weak
isolated d-pawn
last but not least what we should do
against the move b4
which again has the same idea queen can
escape
via the a3 square but this is
not enough as after b6
queen to e3 a5 getting ready for the
discovery check
so white queen has to get out
and after queen to c1 a catches b4
knight to e2 i propose this very simple
move
b5 and if you count the material
we get three tremendous passport
on the queen side for a piece
and as confirmed by chess and gene it is
again
only black who obtain the huge advantage
from this position
that's it guys i hope you enjoy and
learn this
high-profile trap in the queen's gambit
accepted
as i have shown in this video once your
opponent reached to this position
if you don't know what he is doing then
the game can be finished
very quickly and even though if he knows
the theory
the resulting position is always
favoring
the black camp you can use this line
as a complete surprise weapon against a
d4 player
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care